[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'analyse sur
Public Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
et voici le sommaire de ce 26 octobre
c'est un cri d'alarme lancé par des
milliers de soignants en urgence
pédiatrique qui ne peuvent plus traiter
leur petit malade dans de bonnes
conditions à l’hôpital certains sont
transférés à des centaines de kilomètres
pour être prise en charge une crise
symbolique d'un système hospitalier à
bout de souffle ce sera notre déballe
actu dans une minute et puis comme tous
les soirs cette semaine focus sur les
défis énergétiques que la France doit
relever après le nucléaire hier on
décortique ce soir le retard français en
matière d'éolienne le plan du
gouvernement pour y remédier et les
critiques que certains politiques
expriment
faisons pression sur les mairies des
petites communes sur les mers des
petites communes l'implantation se fait
à marche forcée à la demande du
Président de la République à titre
d'exemple la troisième circonscription
de la Charente dont je suis l'élu
possède déjà une centaine d'éoliennes
plus 100 en cours de construction 300 en
instruction atteignant se ratio
lamentable du néolienne pour 6 habitants
dans certaines communes
l'éolien pilier indispensable de la
transition écologique pour les uns
aberration visuelles sonores et
économique pour les autres ne ratez pas
notre second débat dans 45 minutes mais
d'abord donc la crise des urgences
pédiatriques le plan du gouvernement
pour y remédier avec Guillaume Bertrand
un plan d'action à 150 millions d'euros
c'est la réponse du gouvernement à la
crise des urgences pédiatriques et plus
globalement à celle de tous les services
en tension à l'hôpital vendredi le
collectif pédiatrie avait publié une
lettre ouverte à Emmanuel Macron ce
lundi le même collectif fustige la
solution de l'exécutif la réponse
politique est irresponsable au Sénat le
sentiment est partagé par les
socialistes 150 millions c'est tout à
fait anecdotique c'est-à-dire que il
faut pas poser les choses en termes du
nombre de millions qui sont mis au
milliards qui seraient mis sur la table
par exemple il y a un problème dont tous
les soignants nous disent qu'il est
majeur et en particulier en pédiatrie
c'est la sous-rémulation du travail de
nuit et des week-ends quand une
infirmière gagne seulement 10 euros de
plus parce qu'elle travaille la nuit et
ben elle ne veut plus travailler la nuit
alors comment ces 150 millions sont-ils
utilisés ce sont les agences régionales
de santé et les professionnels qui
devront en décider dans les jours qui
viennent l'appel de la pédiatrie a été
déclenchée par une épidémie de
bronchiolite pour y faire face des plans
blancs seront déclenchés localement la
sénatrice Véronique Guillotin médecin de
profession appelle à une vision à long
terme de l'hôpital oui il faut faire ce
chèque 8 il faut donner un signe 8 il
faut prendre des mesures effectivement
de mon dos aux parents de peut-être
appeler le 15 avant d'y aller pour parce
qu'on est toujours sur des mesures
d'urgence et il les faut ces mesures
d'urgence elles sont nécessaires mais à
côté de ces mesures d'urgence il faut
qu'on entame une réflexion profonde de
transformation notre système de santé le
ministère de la Santé a également promis
des Assises de la pédiatrie au printemps
prochain
comment sauver les urgences pédiatriques
comment réformer plus généralement ce
système piatrique également en ville
voilà selon ton on va parler tout de
suite avec Florence lassarade sénatrice
LR de Gironde bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes pédiatre c'est important de le
spécifier évidemment Frédéric valthou
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes député de
Seine-et-Marne porte-parole d'horizon
ancien président de la Fédération
hospitalière de France j'accueille
également Patrick Pelloux bonsoir
bienvenue président de l'Association des
médecins urgentistes de France et
Mathieu croissanto éditorialiste
politique bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à
vous je vais reprendre pour commencer et
vous lire un extrait de de cette lettre
ouverte signée donc par des milliers de
soignants destinés aux présidents de la
République publié vendredi nous ferons
le maximum pour offrir les meilleurs
soins possibles aux enfants nous
garderons des enfants sur des brancards
aux urgences rassureront des parents
désemparés de voir leur enfant transféré
dans un hôpital à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres nous justifierons une sortie
prématurée d'hospitalisation sur un
enfant
fragile pour libérer une précieuse place
qui accueillera un enfant un autre
enfant devenu plus urgent et plus grave
voilà ce qui était ce qui décrivent
c'est leur quotidien il y a eu ce plan
d'urgence du gouvernement on l'a cité
150 millions d'euros pour l'ensemble des
services en tension à l'hôpital Florence
Larade
ces plans blancs locaux c'est 150
millions d'euros débloqué est-ce que ça
vous semble à la hauteur de ce que c'est
soignant décrivent dans leur lettre
ouverte bah écoutez d'abord un plan
blanc ça met l'hôpital en difficulté sur
d'autres d'autres rubriques parce que ça
veut dire qu'on annule toutes les
interventions chirurgicales que les
parents attendaient peut-être justement
par manque de chirurgien depuis un
certain temps donc on désorganise
complètement pour une pathologie que
qu'on traite tous les ans
de bronchiolite qui provoque ça
c'est un révélateur mais depuis
2020 2021 on a mis des masques donc les
enfants n'ont pas attrapé de brocoli
tout il y en a ça a été beaucoup plus
anecdotique on a on fait semblant de
découvrir le ministre découvrez cette
pathologie qui qui a toujours existé et
qui était
suivi par les kinésithérapeutes or
l'achat et ça décrété que la
kinésithérapie c'était dangereux dans la
bronchi l'élément qui a suffi à
fragiliser complètement ce système
puisque il y a pu se résout de kiné pour
pour filtrer les bronchiolites et faites
cette surveillance de week-end ou dont
on avait l'habitude moi là je suis
complètement
perplexe devant cette bronchiolite qu'on
sait prendre en charge normalement alors
on y reviendra dans un instant puisque
c'est la question que vous avez abordé
au Sénat tout à l'heure et le ministre
de la Santé vous a répondu on va le voir
dans un ensemble et je voudrais vous
donner la parole aux uns et aux autres
une première fois
Cédric valent tout juste pour bien
comprendre parce que 150 millions
d'euros pour l'ensemble des services en
tension à l'hôpital donc ça veut dire
que c'est pas seulement pour les
urgences pédiatriques on a bien pas pris
la même chose
j'ai compris 150 millions d'euros pour
être franc j'ai pas bien compris à quoi
ça allait être affecté et je pense qu'il
y a pas encore le détail des de
l'affectation de 650 millions d'euros
mais combien même ça serait 200 millions
d'euros ou 120 millions d'euros plus ou
moins enfin le problème c'est que on
donne toujours le sentiment de mettre
plus d'argent dans un hôpital qui
aujourd'hui était puisé et et qui
devrait être traité différemment que
simplement aller de crise en crise et de
Somme d'urgence débloquée en somme
d'urgence débloquée on a parce que de
cette manière là on a l'impression que
c'est un tonneau sans fin et que il faut
déverser des versets comme si c'était la
réponse qui serait qui est attendue et
qui serait nécessaire non je pense que
alors ça va être l'objet il faut être
positif ça va être le l'objet du du CNR
santé et de cette concertation
qui a lancé le président de la
République et dont on attend des
conclusions en janvier donc janvier
c'est dans trois mois ça va arriver
assez vite mais aujourd'hui il faut
traiter l'hôpital
et le système de santé d'ailleurs ce que
le sujet n'est pas l'hôpital dans ces
quatre murs c'est le système de santé
qui dysfonctionne complètement qui est
en train de qui est complètement
déstabilisé et ça depuis des années sauf
que chaque année qui passe il est un peu
plus fragile le système de santé et
qu'il faut tout remettre à plat
réellement tout remettre à plat sur
l'équilibre entre la vie des l'hôpital
sur le fonctionnement de l'hôpital sur
le financement de l'hôpital sur la
tractivité des carrières des métiers
enfin il y a un chantier énorme qui est
un chantier d'un quinquennat d'ailleurs
c'est pas une loi c'est un quinquennat
on va y revenir évidemment en détail en
essayant au moins au début de ce débat
de rester concentré sur la question de
la pédiatrie et de ces urgences
pédiatriques Patrick Pelloux pourquoi
est-ce que pourquoi c'est aussi critique
et en quoi s'est révélateur je reviens
ce que vous disiez de d'un hôpital parce
que c'est très intéressant ce que disait
la sénatrice il suffit de d'un petit
changement pour que par un effet domino
le système s'effondre d'une certaine
façon et alors ce qui est encore plus
cynique sur la situation comme vous le
dites forment c'est que l'épidémie de
bronchiolite ça c'est les courbes de
santé publique France il faut bien
comprendre que l'épidémie de cette année
elle n'a strictement rien d'exceptionnel
c'est la même que l'année dernière mais
c'est juste c'est les besoins des
malades ne sont plus en rapport avec les
moyens qu'on a à l'hôpital et l'hôpital
s'est effondré et il s'est effondré
pourquoi parce que le personnel est
parti parce que les carrières comme vous
dites ne sont dû attractives les
salaires n'ont pas été augmentés comme
il aurait fallu je rappelle que les
salaires des personnels infirmières
aide-soignantes on est encore à la 18e
place des pays de l'OCDE on est même pas
dans la moyenne
vous avez l'inflation vous avez le
logement qui était effrayant et
tellement coûteux à Paris et les
personnels sont partis ce qui fait que
vous avez plein de services les lions
fermés mais à vous entendre là moi je me
mets à la place de des parents ou des
grands-parents qui nous regardent et qui
peuvent être légitimement inquiets il y
a pas de réponse court terme quoi il y a
pas de solution miracle de solutions
d'urgence il y en a on va y revenir si
vous voulez la réaction qu'on a eu et
les signatures là c'est parce que
justement on pense aux parents et aux
enfants parce que même si vous regardez
ce qui se passe sur Paris par exemple à
Paris vous avez deux unités mobiles
hospitalières c'est-à-dire deux de
véhicules de SAMU pédiatriques un Robert
Debré un équerre bon qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers jours bah dans la
nuit les deux véhicules il y en a un qui
part à Amiens il y en a un qui part à
Chartres pour emmener des enfants qui
sont des tresses respiratoires aiguës
voilà bah vous n'avez plus de Spurs sur
Paris pourquoi il y en a plus parce que
il y a plus de place en réanimation et
et les pédiatres à l'heure actuelle ont
un combat c'est d'éviter le drame pour
des enfants va y en avoir parce que là
ils sont vraiment acculés par le fait
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de répondre
cette année à l'épidémie alors que les
autres années on y arrive et c'est vrai
que si vous voulez après on va peut-être
parler sur les propositions et les
solutions bien sûr mais là je vais pas
jouer les Cassandre mais c'est juste que
ce qui s'est passé pour la pédiatrie
dans quelques semaines je reviendrai je
vous dirai la même chose pour l'adulte
ce matin il y avait 147 malades sur des
brancards sur les hôpitaux de Paris
qu'attendait un lit d'hospitalisation
147 alors on va voir tout de suite grâce
à Audrey betase ce qui s'est dit au
Sénat aujourd'hui sur ce sur cette
question bonsoir
Audrey bienvenue cette question des
urgences pédiatriques elle s'est donc
invitée dans les débats lors des
questions oui deux questions ont été
posées à ce sujet la première par la
voix de la Sénat service communiste
Laurence Cohen la deuxième c'est vous
qui l'avez posé au ministre envahit
revenir pour faire face à la crise
pédiatrique causée par la pénurie de
personnel et par l'épidémie de
bronchiolique vous en avez parlé le
gouvernement a annoncé dimanche un grand
plan d'urgence le déclenchement de plan
blanc de manière locale le déblocage de
150 millions d'euros une rustine pour la
sénatrice Cohen
4000 professionnels en médiatrie
viennent de lancer un appel au président
de la République dénonçant les
conditions désastreuses de prise en
charge des enfants transfert multiples
affectation dans des services adultes
non appropriés sortie trop précoce des
programmations d'opérations mises en
danger de petits patients ce n'est pas
la faute de la bronchiolite mais bien de
la politique une menée depuis des années
dans les hôpitaux un coup de restriction
budgétaire successives et irresponsable
des cris d'alarmes sont lancées
régulièrement par des professionnels
notre groupe les relais ici dans
l'hémicycle vous les ignorez comme tous
vos prédécesseurs le ministre de la
Santé qui a rappelé qu'il suivait le
problème de très près que des de la
pédiatrie serait organisée au printemps
et que les coupes budgétaires ce n'était
pas totalement la faute de ce
gouvernement
c'est un certain nombre de choses que
l'hôpital n'allait pas bien depuis
plusieurs mois permettez-moi de vous
dire que l'hôpital ne va pas bien depuis
plusieurs années plusieurs dizaines
d'années grâce
ou à cause de politique comptable je
vous rejoins dont un certain nombre ont
été votés par l'ensemble du Parlement
depuis malheureusement trop longtemps ce
qui concerne l'engagement de ce
gouvernement en ce qui concerne
l'engagement depuis 2017 du président de
la République ce sont 53 milliards
d'euros qui ont été mis en plus dans
l'hôpital pour répondre certes à des
problèmes conjoncturels mais également à
des problèmes structurels le ministre a
souligné que la crise était exacerbée
par la pénurie de bronchiolite à cette
occasion madame la sénatrice vous avez
rappelé que la bronchiolite c'est tous
les ans vous avez même avancé une
solution faire appel au kinésithérapeute
pour prendre en charge les petits
patients ça se faisait avant ça ne se
fait plus maintenant on écoute la
réponse du ministre
Autorité de santé à relever que
certaines pratiques de kinésithérapie
habituelles faites sur la bronchiolite
sont dangereuses qu'il faut les arrêter
donc la place est maintenant beaucoup
moins importante des kinésithérapeutes
dans cette pathologie précise alors où
et comment savoir où faire prendre en
charge son enfant lorsqu'on a une crise
de bronchiolite des difficultés
respiratoires et bien je le redis aux
parents si vous ne savez pas si vous
n'avez pas de médecin traitant faites le
15 appelez le SAMU vous y trouverez des
professionnels des professionnels
compétents qui pourront vous diriger
vers le meilleur parcours de soins pour
votre enfant voilà la réponse du
ministre qui fait réagir en plateau le
ministre qui a donné rendez-vous à tous
les sénateurs pour donner plus de moyens
à l'hôpital lors de l'examen du budget
de la Sécurité sociale qui arrive c'est
la merci Audrey vous dites c'est
dramatique pourquoi parce que
discréditer de cette façon le kiné qui
ce qui connaît son métier moi j'ai
travaillé pendant 30 ans avec la
présidente de l'Ordre des médecins qui
étaient à 100 mètres de mon cabinet on a
mis au des techniques de surveillance le
kiné n'est pas là pour mettre la tête en
bas de l'enfant y compris le moins etc
il adapte ses gestes et ses conseils aux
parents ça peut être un simple lavage de
nez c'est un réseau de surveillance et
qui permet de rassurer complètement le
médecin que j'étais et les médecins
peuvent largement y compris les
urgentistes s'appuyer sur ce réseau
parce que ce réseau existait depuis deux
ans là pourquoi on l'a supprimé c'était
inutile elle n'a jamais dit que c'était
dangereux elle a dit que c'était inutile
résultat les parents ont arrêté les
médecins arrêtés de prescrire de la kiné
et on est on se prive complètement et ça
c'est de la délégation de tâches en plus
on est typiquement dans le dans l'outil
et la coordination donc l'Aquitaine a
repris à qui respit par exemple et
ça va mal en Aquitaine le ministre n'est
pas au courant il m'a dit à Bordeaux
tout va bien mais c'est pas vrai on
arrive quand même à diminuer de 13% les
consultations
à l'hôpital à nos urgences grâce au kiné
il faut quand même pas se priver de des
professionnels connaissent le problème
mais je suis assez d'accord il faut
faire plus confiance à l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
enfin ce sujet renvoie de choses d'abord
effectivement
à cette confiance qu'on peut faire qu'on
peut donner là c'est les kiné dans
d'autres exemples c'est les infirmières
on parlait avant l'émission des
certificats qu'on fait faire aux enfants
pour aller faire du sport est-ce qu'il
faut forcément aller le demander à des
médecins ce qu'on peut des infirmières
peuvent pas le le faire si tentait que
c'est certificats soient utiles enfin
bref mais ça sert à rien moi c'est quand
même des choses
les pompiers qui font des des gestes
médicaux la deuxième chose c'est de la
gouvernement qui a un système de santé
qui est complètement confus et que là
Haute Autorité de Santé aujourd'hui mais
c'est tout un tas d'agences qui ont
poussé ces 15 dernières années qui
parfois gère chacun dans leur coin
prescrive des choses sans tenir compte
de ce qui est aussi la réalité des
forces sur le terrain en termes de de
soignants mobilisables qui qui
fonctionne et d'organisation de le
terrain et donc c'est vrai que il y a un
grand travail aussi de clarification du
rôle de chacun de chacune de ces agents
de l'autre côté de la barrière il y a
encore quelques mois donc j'aurais pu
dire la même chose que tout que vous
tous
urgentiste mais voilà et donc il le sait
tout ça et on a failli ressortir les
communiquer de presse en françois Brown
qui a un ami c'est un ami en plus un qui
sortait il y a quelques mois et là il
bon alors c'est très bien mais il a
changé de métier il est devenu homme
politique j'ai beaucoup de respect je
peux pas commencer c'est pas ça doit pas
être très compliqué de dire je reste sur
le la question toute simple de pourquoi
on a mis les clés en dehors du processus
c'est pas bien compliqué ça nous dit que
les uns les autres il faut les
réintégrer de les réintégrer le ministre
a un truc et c'était l'objet d'un des
débats avec lui depuis à peu près un an
c'est qu'il pense qu'on peut tout gérer
par le fameux SAS c'est à dire le SAMU
qui répond au téléphone et qu'on peut
tout gérer par téléphone il oublie juste
une chose c'est que les malades ça
s'examine et les gens veulent alors des
médecins des soignants les prendre en
charge et que là maintenant j'ai envie
de vous dire le travail clinique a été
totalement discrédité c'est à dire que
maintenant faut plus toucher les balades
faut faire de la téléconsultation des
trucs mais les gens veulent pas ça ils
veulent voir des soignants ils veulent
qu'on s'occupe d'eux d'accord et c'est
ça le problème quand vous dites forment
justement on a on a négligé l'appui
d'équidé je me souviens il y a encore
deux ans et je ne me souviens pas
d'avoir vu des unes disons les
kinésithérapeutes ont tué des enfants en
faisant de la kiné respiratoire jamais
ça n'a jamais existé là on a changé le
truc et on a tout déstabilisé et vous
ajoutez à ça que par rapport à ce qui
était dit tout à l'heure dans votre
portage le travail de nuit n'intéresse
plus parce que alors ça faut avouer que
ce n'est pas la faute ça c'est
historique ce n'est pas la faute de ton
ancienne boutique la FAF ni du ministère
parce que quand il y a eu le Ségur la
première chose qui avait été dit vous
l'aviez apporter vous aviez dit il faut
valoriser la permanence de soins c'est à
dire le salaire des infirmières des
médecins qui travaillent la nuit le
week-end etc qui a refusé les syndicats
de praticiens hospitaliers parce qu'ils
voulaient augmenter de deux échelons les
fans carrière et donc nous on a protesté
avec les anesthésistes mais ça a tout
déstabilisé parce que quand une affirme
pas il y a une part de responsabilité
des médecins eux-mêmes c'est bien sûr
des syndicats
et ils ont été choisis mais oui mais oui
et alors
du coup maintenant tout le monde rame
parce que tout le monde le dit ça a été
dit passer à tout le monde le dit la
permanence de soins c'est à dire le jour
les week-ends
doit être valorisé or et ben il y a plus
d'argent et quand ils annoncent ça fait
rire tout le monde c'est 150 millions
parce que on sait pas où ils vont aller
hein ça représente 10 millions à peu
près par un peu plus de 10 millions par
Agence Régionale qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
en faire tous les services et c'est pas
de l'argent qui va être pérenne c'est un
agent une touche donc on ne peut pas
embaucher or ce qu'il faut et si vous
voulez relancer les hôpitaux faut
d'abord s'attaquer à l'échelle aux
barèmes aux échelles de salaire et
valoriser les carrières financièrement
alors les solutions à long terme on va
essayer d'y revenir et d'y consacrer du
temps mais peut-être Matthieu c'est
intéressant la réponse du gouvernement
parce que elle a été rapide ben c'est du
rarement vu hein vendredi 4000 soignants
qui adressent une lettre au président de
la République et dès dimanche le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
Vérand qui annonce un plan d'action
immédiat alors le président de la
République a été interpellé par un
collectif dit-il il a pris connaissance
de s'interpellation il a sollicité
immédiatement la première ministre amie
de la santé pour qu'un plan d'action
immédiat puisse être mis en place tout
ça c'est ce qui a expliqué Olivier Véran
bon ok on rappelle que lui-même est
médecin et hospitalier donc c'est voilà
et ancien ministre de la Santé signe que
la crise est préoccupante signe qu'elle
est prise au sérieux c'est en tout cas
tout ce que a voulu montrer le
gouvernement qu'elle est prise au
sérieux au plus haut sommet de l'État
souvenir qui aiment de toutes les
critiques qu'il y avait eu de la gestion
covid mais c'est le signe aussi que
l'exécutif attiré les leçons à ses yeux
de ce qui s'était passé les semaines
précédentes sur un sujet qui a rien à
voir la crise des carburants parce qu'il
avait été accusé de manque
d'anticipation de manque de réactivité
le gouvernement ne s'était pas montré à
la hauteur pour 3/4 des français ce qui
avait agacé au plus haut point le chef
de l'État qui avait dû finir par mettre
lui-même les mains dans le cambouis et
ce qu'il avait évidemment énervé cette
fois-ci sur un sujet aussi grave que la
santé de nos enfants donc pour le
gouvernement pas question de perdre du
temps ni même de donner le sentiment de
perdre du temps d'où l'annonce de cette
réponse immédiate avec un déblocage avec
les fameux 150 millions disponibles tout
de suite après préciser le milieu de la
santé c'est que malgré la rapidité de
cette réaction et ben les retours des
soignants sont dubitatifs voire critique
quoi mais voilà c'est un peu infernal la
politique faut le dire parce qu'on se
demande du coup c'est le gouvernement
n'a pas été trop vite ou trop à côté de
la plaque ces mesures immédiates elles
ont pas convaincu les soignants non ils
ont évoqué le manque de moyens serrer
dans la lettre mais aussi l'hémorragie
de personnel vous en avez parlé la
fermeture des lits le poids de la
bureaucratie même la perte de sens
autant de sujets qui figurant au menu
des discussions de d'une future réforme
de notre système de santé au sein du
Conseil national de la refondation et
puis de futurs Assises Nationales de la
pédiatrie un nouveau rendez-vous fixé au
printemps 2023 mais voilà c'est la fois
3 rapide trop court trop pas assez et
puis trop loin trop lointain et les
soignants veulent aujourd'hui discuter
avec qui directement avec le Président
j'ai envie de dire carambar encore raté
c'est intéressant parce que Mathieu
reprenait finalement en quelque sorte la
communication ça vous faisait mais ultra
réagir Florence Larsa vous dites la
salade vous dites c'est de la gomme vous
dites mais je reviens on peut pas dire
on a un problème on fait un chèque
que les soignants on va pas les trouver
comme ça d'un claquement de doigts parce
que là c'est un manque de soignant dans
les services que le gouvernement est
à la manœuvre on sait bien pour former
une infirmière il faut pas six ans pour
former parce qu'il manque de
puéricultrice il manque d'auxiliaire
l'agriculture tout ça ça peut ça ça peut
se faire et quand on voit en en parler
tout à l'heure le
recrutement actuel des médecins par le
système passe là ce qu'elle personne ne
comprend rien sans possibilité de
recrutement de redoublement et et qui
fait que quelqu'un voulait faire matiner
il va se trouver à faire du droit puis
finalement il est pas mécontent ou alors
il va partir dans un dans un filière
sport
qui peut comprendre ce que devient la
médecine en France moi je suis la
cinquième génération de massage des
élevé dans un cabinet médical j'ai fait
j'ai fait encore comme sénatrice des
astreintes le week-end parce que on
n'était pas sûr d'avoir quelqu'un pour
ma maternité et et finalement moi on me
dit à Bordeaux il y a pas de problème
j'ai eu les le médecin il n'y a aucun
problème à Bordeaux mais mais dans quel
dans quel mais je suis allé voir comme
j'ai pas pu faire de réplique parce que
j'avais une réplique un peu un peu
cognée sur la mortalité infantile et on
est passé du 7e au 25e rang en Europe
donc ça quand même si on se préoccupe ça
c'est que là c'est très grave donc je
suis allé voir le ministre et
il me dit mais Bordeaux mais moi les
nouvelles de Bordeaux que j'ai sont
bonnes tout va bien à Bordeaux alors
j'ai l'impression qu'une fois qu'on est
ministre et ben on a plus les remonter
de la basse et les informations
je vais vous donner la parole juste
après Patrick mais je veux entendre
voilà qui est je rappelle que
vous êtes à la fois ancien prénom la
Fédération hospitalière de France porte
parole d'horizon donc d'une certaine
façon on peut attendre de vous vous
défendiez le gouvernement voilà
je défends l’humilité sur ces sujets qui
sont des sujets compliqués je rappelle
que les médecins qui a aujourd'hui
rentrent dans la carrière sont les
médecins qu'on commençait leur formation
dans les fin des années 2000 2007 2013
s'ils sont généralistes 2012-2013 c'est
à dire
sous des quinquennat précédentes de
présidents différents et que si jamais
eux-mêmes avaient très bien anticipé les
choses sur le nombre de médecins qui
arrivent voilà les choses ne seraient
pas celle-là donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que soyons vous dites également
sur ce sujet là sur ce sujet là soyons
humbles il y a pas à s'envoyer à la
figure des il y a depuis 6 ans et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait etc il y a eu
quand même deux années de crise qui ont
fait qu'il y a des soignants qu'on jeté
l'éponge parce que l'épuisement parce
que la fatigue dans un système
dysfonctionnant une crise comme celle
qu'on a vécu a effectivement mis à
genoux certains soignants et on peut les
comprendre voilà mais il y a eu Ségure
de la santé alors c'est ça la question
c'est pour est-ce qu'il y a pas une
occasion manquée à ce moment-là on a
déjà eu ce débat ici sur sur d'autres
huit milliards d'euros pour les
rémunérations à l'hôpital un peu plus si
on considère le privé le médico-social
etc c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais
fait donc je dis pas que ça suffit bien
sûr à résoudre le problème puisque c'est
un début de commencement de redressement
donc un début de commencement c'est pas
ça peut paraître modeste 19 milliards
d'euros investi dans les murs
hospitaliers pour essayer de remettre du
matériel remettre des murs à peu près là
aussi on était tombé tellement bas en
investissements hospitalier que c'est un
début de redressement mais on va voir
les effets dans quelques années donc
c'est un paquebot qui est très long à
redresser le système de santé il y a
encore énormément de réformes apportées
mais il y a aussi quelque part un peu
des signaux que ça y est le sujet est
compris que le le la gestion comptable
du système de santé qui a quand même été
douloureuse depuis le début des années
2000 jusqu'à la fin des années 2010
comment ça effectivement être on passe
cette époque et on arrive à une autre
époque mais ça va être très long je vous
donne la parole tout de suite un
témoignage sur finalement peut-être
cette occasion manquée du sigurer la
santé en tout cas voilà le quotidien
d'une infirmière elle est justement à
l'hôpital pour enfants de la Timone à
Marseille rencontré par Sandra serreira
segaya il y a quelques mois elle se dit
totalement ballottée faute de personnel
des services à l'autre
à droite à gauche donc on se retrouve à
travailler en cardiologie on se retrouve
à travailler des fois on encohémato
alors que c'est pas du tout notre
spécialité qu'on n'est pas du tout formé
à ça sans rigoler ça peut aller jusqu'à
la mort du patient sur des certaines
dosages de médicaments qu'on connaît pas
forcément quand on est habitué à
travailler dans un service c'est les
prescriptions les connaît les
médicaments on les connaît quand on est
ballotté dans un autre service on
connaît pas les traitements donc s'il y
a une erreur de prescription on peut ne
pas l'avoir c'est c'est archi stressant
en fait c'est très stressant Patrick
lourd c'est un service de décrire parce
que plus les conditions de travail se
dégradent pour les gens partent et puis
ceux qui restent dans des conditions de
travail qui se dégradent et il tombe en
burnout c'est ce qu'on appelle la
spirale sociale infernale et ça se
dégrade pour faire très très vite il y a
il y a deux choses qu'on cassé bien le
système de santé 2002
Mattéi et Chirac qui disent c'est fini
il y a plus d'obligation de faire des
gardes de nuit pour le monde libéral
très bien ça a déstabilisé toute
l'organisation de la permanence des
soins au lieu de trouver quelque chose
qui permettait d'avoir un consensus et
de continuer à avoir ça on a cassé le
système de je suis d'accord rame voilà
deuxième truc qui a cassé et qui est
antinomique de la chose de l'hôpital
public c'est 2007-2008 quand ils disent
on va faire l'hôpital entreprise ça
voulait dire quoi j'ai rien contre
l'entreprise mais chacun dans
soninomique de l'hôpital parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a dit on va
faire la tarification à l'activité les
médecins sont trompés ils ont cru que
d'un coup s'il travaillait plus y gagner
plus souvenez-vous du petit du petit
couplet d'accord en fait pas du tout
l'enveloppe était contenue par les votes
que vous faites c'est à dire le PLFSS
est l'ONDAM d'accord donc du coup et bah
c'est les sardines qui se sont disputés
la même la petite quantité d'huile pour
travailler donc l'hôpital a été mis au
régime sec et puis évidemment c'est ce
que vient de dire l'infirmière là
l'épaule qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a
regroupé les services
alors que les services c'est la cellule
ouvrière d'un hôpital et c'est ce qui
parle à tout le monde on a supprimé les
services on a fait des pôles ce qui fait
que les infirmières qui avaient
l'habitude de travailler dans un service
connaisse les malades connaissent les
médecins les habitudes comme dit la
collègue les traitements elles se sont
trouvées dans des pôles et il y a des
matins ils arrivent on lui tu vas en
endoc et puis
c'est ça tu vas en cardiologie voilà
puis l'emmenant leur dire tu vas en
chirurgie c'est la même chose là c'est
la vente panique sur la faillite de la
chirurgie publique là
chirurgie publique elle s'est quasiment
cassé la figure quel a été la première
mission là sur l'assistance publique ce
sera perçue que les blocs communs parce
qu'ils avaient décidé de faire des blocs
communs étaient une ânerie donc on va
revenir on repart en arrière alors on
repart en arrière donc d'accord pour
refaire des blocs qui font que d'un coup
les infirmières de bloc opératoire vont
pouvoir dire je suis infirmière de bloc
opératoire de chirurgie cardiaque de
chirurgie viscérale de chirurgie
orthopédique et c'est tout ça qui a sapé
le moral des
je reviens je suis un peu têtu moi aux
solutions court terme long terme
Florence la salade est-ce qu'il y a du
personnel formé à la pédiatrie
disponible pour voilà pour remplacer ce
qui partent quoi on n'utilise pas assez
le le personnel libéral il y a à
Bordeaux par exemple un service
d'astreinte de des pédiatres libéraux
sur le secteur d'une clinique qui
permette à certains patients d'éviter
d'aller à l'hôpital je pense qu'il faut
se servir de toutes les personnes dont
on dispose on l'a vu pour le covid il y
a eu quand même un élan important et on
a vu que les gens étaient capables de de
s'organiser mais il faut les laisser
s'organiser aussi sur le terrain et on
est capable de réquisitionner et ça
pardon mais non c'est pas avec de la
réquisition
la réponse c'est forcément
tous les ans donc c'est pas c'est pas
une vraie je pense que décrivent les
médecins c'est quand même le fait de
devoir transférer ce qu'on a raconté
à ce point-là non non je sais bien on
est arrivé on est arrivé
parce que on va passer on va passer une
on va passer une crise très bien là
mettons au printemps on se réveille on
fait des Assises de la pédiatrie tout
l'été enfin l'été va commencer il y a
moins de pathologies et on va dire bon
après tout on y est bien arrivé mais ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut réfléchir c'est
les années suivantes
je vais juste vous poser une question
qui est peut-être complètement naïve
mais je suis sûr que beaucoup de
téléspectateurs se la pose est-ce que la
pédiatrie est à ce point spécifique pour
qu'on puisse pas basculer les enfants en
dédit d'urgence adulte alors c'est très
intéressant parce que ça a été un débat
il y a trois quatre jours notamment à
l'Assistance publique à la CME ou en
fait on a réfléchi que l'âge était
probablement une ânerie en fait là j'ai
une Adri et en fait on va raisonner la
prise en charge des malades sur le poids
et en gros imbécile mais un enfant vous
savez il y a des il y a des gamins qui
ont 14 ans qui
parlage on leur dit 15 ans c'est la
pédiatrie mais à 14 ans il faut un mètre
80 ils font 60 kg bah c'est des adultes
donc du coup vous avez un effort qui est
fait là qui est réel vous avez des
réanimateurs adultes des chirurgiens
adultes qui disent ben nous on peut
prendre des gamins s'ils font plus de 35
c'est des petits bébés on est bien
d'accord en dessous voilà en dessous de
30-35 kg c'est spécifique et vous avez
des réanimations qui sont très
compliquées très difficiles sur la
naissance le nouveau-né
l'enfant qui a d'autres pathologies etc
et ça prend beaucoup de temps alors
il faut comprendre c'est que si la
spécialité de pédiatrie c'est une
spécialité jeune elle est arrivée
tardivement dans le dans le mon père qui
était généraliste vous voyez vraiment
pas pourquoi j'allais faire de la
pédiatrie au salut paraissait normal que
le généraliste la fasse sauf que on a
vraiment une utilité sur la prévention
la prescription d'antibiotiques et
d'examens qui est bien le moindre il y a
vraiment une plus-value et il y a une
plus-value également sur le sur la
parentalité il y a des il y a quand même
je vais défendre le métier de pédiatre
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on
François brun l'a dit on va s'appuyer
sur les généralistes il existe tout un
réseau de pédiatrie angulatoire qui
travaille vraiment et qui proposait
solutions et qui fait de la prévention
en plus et se priver de cette spécialité
moi ça me ça m'ennuie mais je reviens et
je pense que personne ne le souhaite ici
mais je reviens à la question de la
réquisition parce que il y a toujours
ces dans tous nos débats sur la le CM de
santé français quand on parle de
l'hôpital on en vient à parler aussi de
la santé en ville et c'est vrai aussi
pour la pédiatrie regardez cette cette
carte des déserts médicaux en pédiatrie
elle est assez facile à lire plus la
couleur plus bleue est claire plus la
situation est critique avec les
départements les plus clairs on est à
moins de 1,7 spécialistes vous voyez
entre 0 et 1,7%.000 habitants c'est
quand même assez vertigineux il y a
certains départements où ils ont évalué
il manque une quarantaine de pédiatres
de villes pour un suivi normal des
enfants malades c'est le cas par exemple
dans les départements du des Hauts de
France Nord ou Pas de Calais donc je
reviens vers vous freeze tout parce que
j'entendais la solution de faire
confiance aux pédiatre de ville pour
désengorger les urgences hospitalières
sauf qu'il y a des départements ou c'est
juste impossible non mais de toute façon
il faut pas se leurrer dans l'avenir il
va falloir rééquilibrer les droits et
devoirs de chacun des acteurs du système
de santé et quand Patrick Pelou disait
un des mots à des moments où on a
commencé à dysfonctionner c'est quand on
a effectivement allégé l'effort des de
garde sur la médecine libérale on va
leur en 2003 effectivement derrière ça a
provoqué le nombre de choc sur les
urgences sur le le décalage entre des
modes d'exercice entre le public et
privé qui n'ont fait que se creuser au
fil du temps et qui à un moment il va
falloir répondre
bien sûr qu'il faut encore faut-il que
les jeunes médecins le veuillent on a
fait un débat sur les internes il y a
pas très longtemps sur ce plateau vous
étiez là d'ailleurs
mais ils ont pas la même vision de la
médecine ils veulent pas forcément faire
le même nombre d'heures le même nombre
de garde
je suis tout à fait d'accord mais je
suis venu être complètement ringard mais
si vous voulez vivre en société c'est
des droits et des devoirs autant le
droit social vous m'avez toujours sur la
barricade mais les devoirs aussi en fait
et vous pouvez pas et quand vous faites
médecin vous pouvez pas vous dire je
vais faire médecine je vais avoir des
super diplômes et puis à la fin vous
dire bah finalement je m'installe en
vide et je vais faire du Botox parce que
moi je serai tranquille et je travaille
pas donc il faut valoriser le travail de
ceux qui font du travail de nuit etc et
en effet il faut pas qu'un petit nombre
fasse le travail du plus grand nombre
sur le plus grand espace oui mais je
pense que vous dites mais ça rejoint la
notion de perte de sens qui est pas
seulement d'ailleurs à l'hôpital ou dans
le système de santé qui se pose dans
énormément de secteurs d'activités en
France avec une génération qui arrive
sur le marché de travail et qui veut pas
forcément les mêmes conditions de
travail que la génération ou les
générations qui précèdent si on leur dit
si si je vous assure et par exemple la
Science Publique on travaille sur une
charte sur la permanence de soins avec
les internes ils sont très volontaires
simplement ceux qui veulent c'est en
effet aussi un tronfort social comme
tout le monde mais je vais vous dire ils
ont pas tort parce que quand vous
regardez l'espérance de vie des gens qui
sont en décalage horaire et qui
travaillent la nuit etc bah il y a pas
photo il faut améliorer ça et donc il y
a pas de conflit générationnel c'est
juste d'un coup de fixer des règles qui
soient en fait des règles basées sur les
valeurs humanistes et qui font faut pas
oublier on soigne pas des lignes
comptables ou un tableau Excel on soigne
des malades des familles voyez donc d'un
coup quand on dit on peut tout faire en
ville c'est pas tout à fait le cas
notamment chez les familles les plus
alors pardon la perte de sang chez les
Hospitaliers elle est née aussi du fait
qu'on constate année après année qui est
effectivement un écart qui se creuse
entre une médecine à deux je vais pas
dire une médecine à deux vitesses mais
des systèmes qui aujourd'hui répondent à
des règles totalement différentes et
effectivement selon que vous travaillez
à l'hôpital vous soumis à des gardes
vous êtes soumis à la pression de
l'activité vous êtes soumis assez
effectivement ces épidémies qu'on que
l'on voit etc et puis pardon mais il y a
une autre médecine qui fonctionne avec
des règles qui sont totalement
différentes or le soin c'est une mission
d'intérêt général la nation paie pour le
soin et la nation à forme des gens aussi
pour soigner et donc cette mission là
elle doit s'accompagner effectivement de
contrepartie qui sont assumés cette
mission d'intérêt général c'est les
gants
de médecine aujourd'hui on s'engage à
faire des gardes que l'on soit à
l'hôpital ou qu'on soit en ville
là aussi la population soignante je
crois que c'est un tiers des médecins
qui ont plus de 60 ans moi mes collègues
à l'hôpital en réa on CHU soit 162 ans
ils font plus de garde de nuit on va
expliquer au médecin et qui en a combien
qui ont plus de 65 enfin on est vraiment
sur une population qui est âgée donc
c'est pas les les je pense qu'il faut
vraiment augmenter quand on dit apertus
il faut il faut beaucoup plus de
médecins à l'hôpital quand il traverse
la rue parfois il va gagner trois fois
plus en ayant plus de garde en
choisissant son temps
j'ai pas dit tous les spécialités mais
prenez la radiologie par exemple voilà
ou l'anesthésie
et donc ça veut dire que du de l'autre
côté de la Russie la clinique
effectivement l'autre côté de la rue ça
vive a totalement changé
son cas son pouvoir d'achat va
totalement être transformé et bon voilà
donc si vous voulez toutes ces
différences qui sont de plus en plus
prégnants dans notre système de santé
elle crée effectivement des tensions
très fortes et elles créent des
incompréhensions qui débouchent sur la
perte de sens chez beaucoup
d'hospitaliers un autre témoignage tiré
du même reportage de Sandra cerquera
dans ton avis un extrait tout à l'heure
on est donc toujours à l'hôpital de la
Timone hôpital pour enfants à Marseille
c'est Fabienne qui est cadre infirmier à
cette hôpital elle parle de du choc qui
aurait dû avoir lieu après le Ségur de
la santé et c'est très après on est dans
l'absentéisme regardez
je choque d'être activité qui devait
avoir lieu poségur n'a pas du tout eu et
moi je reste persuadée qu'il y a pas que
une problématique financière et de
salaire parce que si les conditions de
travail étaient acceptables si on si on
avait du matériel pour travailler si on
demandait pas aux équipes tous les jours
de faire des changements on était à 17%
d'absentéisme donc c'est quand même
énorme donc oui on gère la pénurie au
quotidien il nous reste moins de 10
minutes je voudrais qu'on essaye de
faire avancer un peu des solutions
Patrick Pelloux il va y avoir
effectivement la lancé naturelle de la
formation des assistants
ça ne peut pas marcher je pense d'abord
si vous voulez quand vous voyez le
nombre de personnels d'infirmières qui
ont quitté le métier ce que vient de
dire là la collègue et qui sont à Pôle
emploi en fait donc vous dites qu'il y a
un problème sur les salaires ça je n'en
démords pas il y a un problème sur les
salaires augmenter les salaires de 20%
vous allez voir comment elle reviendront
mais en effet c'est un suffisant elle
reviendront mais il faut que le
management change à l’hôpital ils soient
beaucoup plus bienveillant et que en
effet et ça c'est une vraiment quelque
chose qui revient de manière chronique
dans les revendications des personnels
c'est que quand elles vont être
affiliées à un service de tel ou telle
spécialité elles y restent où elles
évoluent mais elles y restent l'espèce
de changement permanent est absolument
insupportable et par ailleurs et pour
faire suite à ce que disait Frédéric
tout à l'heure dans dans les
modélisations il y a des choses il va
falloir un petit peu arrêter les
certificats médicaux ça a été dit dans
un projet de loi de financement de
sécurité sociale il y a quelques années
mais il faut arrêter de les faire vous
savez qu'il y a 10 à 15% des gens qui
viennent au service des ur pédiatriques
pour faire des certificats de bonne
santé de sport de voyage d'absence
scolaire ou les vaccins qui doivent être
faits dans les PMI par exemple bon bah
ça
va
Protection Maternelle Infantile merci
c'est ceux qui font qui surveillent les
familles les dispensaires bon ben voyez
il y a des tas de petites solutions je
ne crois pas je suis pas d'accord mais
je lui ai déjà dit avec le ministre que
tout soit dans la le tout régulation
parce que les gens nous sommes nous
sommes la dernière lumière allumée les
gens vivent souvent dans des solitudes
il faut les voir faut les examiner et
puis un dernier mot sur la pédiatrie
parce que ça ne va pas sans vous avez
quand même 20 à 30% des lits qui sont
actuellement occupés par des problèmes
de pédopsychiatrie or l'enfant pauvre de
la pédiatrie et l'enfant pauvre de la
psychiatrie c'est la pédopsychiatrie et
on fera beaucoup de progrès dans notre
société si on aide beaucoup d'enfants à
vivre et beaucoup d'adolescents à
comprendre la vie Florence lasarade vous
êtes c'est un triste LR je le rappelle
critique sur le l'action du gouvernement
de et d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 6 ans
mais qu'est-ce que vous proposez pour
voilà à long terme pour une pour
réformer la pédiatrie puis plus
globalement évidemment c'est le système
de santé qui va avec disons qu'il y a
des moyens plus ou moins urgents par
exemple augmenter le nombre le nombre
d'internants pédiatrie ça serait ça
serait intéressant à condition d'avoir
de la pétance pour les gardes de nuit
les astreintes etc donc il faut il faut
qu'il y ait une rémunération
proportionnée à la à l'effort je crois
que ça c'est très important moi je crois
quand même que on a parlé à un moment de
faire un exercice mixte libéral
hospitalier moi ça a été toute ma toute
ma carrière mais j'étais inacception et
c'est là qu'on trouve la liberté c'est à
dire qu'on peut on a on a une liberté
d'esprit qui dit si ça marche pas d'un
côté on pourra aller vers l'autre et je
pense que le le
le médecin et compris le médecin
généraliste aimerait aussi aller dans
l'hôpital pour pour participer aux soins
et pour donc ça ça peut être une piste
pour
que le que le médecin ne se sent pas
isolé dans son exercice je pense c'est
ça serait utile qui est un partage
avec une équipe par moment et puis seul
dans son cabinet où on peut on peut
suivre le patient de façon adaptée sur
une spécialité clinique je pense que
l'examen clinique la pédiatrice c'est
typiquement clinique c'est important on
a des syndicats de pédiatres libéraux
l'Association française de pédiatrie
ambulatoire qui a apporté beaucoup
beaucoup de solutions mais on
ignore ces solutions il y a vraiment moi
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord pour
que ça soit tout hôpital il faut aussi
s'appuyer sur le sur la
sur le secteur qui qui peut apporter
grâce à une certaine liberté je pense
que c'est
peut-être notre ADN de ne pas avoir de
ne pas des exécutants de que le médecin
soit encore un petit peu et encore un
peu le sentiment de pouvoir apporter son
originalité et sa façon de conclusion
pour vous aussi Frédéric valthou si vous
nous dites que c'est pas seulement une
question de milliards d'euros donc c'est
quoi c'est le système qu'il faut
remettre à plat on dit souvent les ARS
voilà c'est faut pardon mais il faut
tout remettre à plat il faut espérer que
le rendez-vous du mois de Janvier
Février c'est-à-dire des annonces postes
CNR Conseil national de la revendation
débouche sur une vision globale
d'ampleur il y a la des
bureaucratisation du système et
effectivement trop dirigisme et les
médecins passent trop de temps à remplir
à faire de l'administratif etc que dans
mon libéral comme dans le monde
hospitalier donc il faut alléger il faut
faire confiance aux acteurs de terrain
pour s'organiser parce que parce que
l'état des forces les cartes le monde
sont pas les mêmes au nord au sud de
l'est à l'ouest et qu'à partir de là il
faut qui qui s'organise entre eux mais
si on est frais concret est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on redonne le pouvoir au
médecin à l'hôpital par exemple est-ce
que le directeur le directeur de
l'hôpital c'est pas un sujet c'est
important
ça rien changé c'est pas un vrai sujet
et puis les médecins en l'occurrence des
pédiatre à s'installer dans les armées
aujourd'hui la forcer l'installation
pardon
pénurie on gère la pénurie
l'installation dirigée oui le jour où on
retrouvera c'est-à-dire dans les années
2030 un nombre de médecins suffisant
peut-être qu'elle a effectivement faudra
veiller à ce que ce chiffre ces médecins
suffisant au niveau national se
répartissent bien sur le territoire et
par refaire les erreurs de 30 ans avant
mais aujourd'hui gérer la pénurie bon ça
sert à rien d'être dirigiste et puis la
dernière chose je vais aller juste un
chiffre 30% de dépenses inutiles dans
notre système de santé et donc il faut
mieux réguler parce qu'il y a pas
forcément de mettre besoin de mettre
plus d'argent mais il faut mieux dép
pour mieux payer les salaires à
l’hôpital pour mieux payer la
consultation du généraliste à 25 euros
pour mieux payer et investir là où on en
a besoin mais ça l'argent faut être un
petit peu plus exigeant et faire en
sorte qu'on dépense pour ce qui
participe pour ce qui concourt vraiment
à l'état de santé des français plutôt
qu'à certaines routes qui existent parce
que dans le système il y a beaucoup de
rentes bon chassons les rente merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat à bientôt évidemment sur ce
plateau et sur public